okay now even though I'm about to talk
about Bluetooth what I want to do is
actually group this under a very large
heading okay
so OH bluetooth is my first one but a
lot of the next ones I'm going to
mention come under the heading of radio
okay
Bluetooth is the first kind of radio
right now when you talk about Bluetooth
what kind of things characterize it
what's it usually for what's it usually
for what kinds of devices do you connect
together with butcher folks you might
connect your keyboard or mouse to your
computer by bluetooth so in that case we
would say peripherals okay good so um
phones they often connect to one of the
most common things they connect to you
apart from each other is cars right so a
hands-free system are you me okay yeah
sure so the microphone those things look
really dorky but um I suppose they're
useful again I suppose you could put
that under the category of peripherals
right they're sort of like a side thing
you can plug in now Bluetooth Bluetooth
is that is the common name right but
actually it has another name a more
specific name which is going to lead me
into discussing another kind of radio
technology so the real technical name
for Bluetooth is ie8 Oh two one five
this is the real name for Bluetooth
except it's a bit of a mouthful and like
the marketing guys are like how can i
how can i market this how can I put this
in the TV advertisement there this
sounds cool it doesn't really so what
we'll do is we'll take apart this some
name and then it'll lead us into another
technology which you're probably already
getting here okay so what do each of
these bits mean I Triple Aim stands for
group of people does anyone know who its
I Triple E so we'll say Akasha
it stands for I think it's the tip it's
the truth wha this software is it's a
shoot-off now I have to be a little
careful here this three e's right I know
what the last one stands for and I know
what one of these stands for I'm not
sure what the second is that so I think
it is it it of electrical let's see how
well my memory goes and then we'll test
it in a second
Electrical and yeah I think it's
eletronic but that doesn't seem right to
me
engineers is it okay sure what is this
it's a bunch of really smart people and
it's to do with it's to do with
engineering particularly stuff that
involves electrical systems right but
these guys are sort of an international
organization and they have to do with
defining standards standards or
protocols if you like things that
everyone needs to agree on
so the lots and lots of different people
can use it okay now you are familiar
with the work of this group even if you
don't think about very much because you
actually use their standards all the
time okay
even though you might not know the name
so for instance let me give you another
standard which you probably use every
day namely I Triple E 260 think it's 260
yeah I believe 260 260 is is a set of
standards made up by these guys to do
with units of measurement so you know
when you are when you write kg okay you
can assume it means kilogram and when
you rien que JIT you can assume it means
clear and the reason why is because
these guys said yeah this is the one
that's going to be the one which we use
all over the world
now you might think well what else would
you use
I mean kilo gram kg right well the thing
is that's in English isn't it right and
this isn't
unit of measurement okay oh and a little
things like say you know later
is a capital L and so milliliter is a
little L little air and a big L things
like that are decided by this
organization okay so anyway that was a
cyber I Triple E 802.15 okay so what did
what did these bits refer to we come
back to okay so 802 a no to actually
refers to all kinds of wireless
communication wireless more specifically
it talked about the wireless
communications that have to do with
variable data packet size but that's not
that big a deal for you guys all I want
to get across is 802 all of the I Triple
E 802 blah blah blah blah blah blah they
all to do with different kinds of
wireless communications and because
there's so many that's why there's a
another number on the end okay lastly 15
refers to a particular group a committee
within the I Triple E that decided all
of the status to do in blue - okay so
group 15 if you like that's a bit
arbitrary it's sort of just in order of
actually both of these numbers are
arbitrary it's just that order they
turned up in which is like 260 is so
much earlier because there's so much
more fundamental and old it's not as
recent as 802 50 okay